[Musique]
cette mélangeur sur la grille de départ
plusieurs vitesses des modèles à moins
de 160 dollars
un circuit rigoureux gagnera deux grands
prix nous avons soumis les mélangeurs à
des préparations spécifiques pour
simuler des utilisations domestiques
glace smoothie vortex veston une
biscuits pulvérisé l'important dans un
mélangeur c'est d'attirer toutes les
produits vers la lame
on voit ici j'ai six lames et mes larmes
vont travailler dans plusieurs plans
contrairement ici seulement quatre
petites lames donc c'est évident que
celui là ici vont moins bien performé
lors de voir comment les biscuits mon
faire pulvériser
avec les biscuits rares ce qui est
intéressant c'est que je commence avec
des gros morceaux
ok donc si l'appareil performe pas bien
on va voir des morceaux plus gros qui
vont rester
donc après les douze coups ici on voit
qu'il reste encore beaucoup de gros
morceau donc on va poursuivre donc on
voit déjà ici apprécié ce coup que 500
mètres quand même assez beau si tous les
modèles arrivent à leur fin certains
sont plus rapides
on le voit bien quand vient le temps de
concasser de la glace donc la glace est
vraiment très très fine
mais on a encore quelques gros morceau
avec les kitchenaid ont une texture
super fine nez une forme certains
modèles ne réussissent pas à broyer la
glace sans intervention après trente
deux impulsions et plusieurs habitations
pontneau toujours de très gros morceau
de glace quelques impulsions ont suffi
aux kitchenette salle tonnes et ninja a
donné une glace bien filmé
pour tester les spots is on a choisi des
ingrédients avec beaucoup de fibres les
ananas
le caire a ajouté aussi quelqu'un
graines de citrouille pour rajouter une
sorte de défi on voit sur la spatule que
tout est lisse mois ont la couleur
espère uniforme les particules semblent
très rare hamilton beach a nécessité
trois producteurs et les autres modèles
pour obtenir un smoothie digne de ce nom
après 90 secondes on voit des monts sont
encore un peu gros vous avez fait aussi
le test du vortex pourquoi en utilisant
un produit qui est blanc avec un coulis
rouge ça nous permet de voir comment que
le rouge se déplacent à l'intérieur du
mélangeur 8 1 2 3 go
donc on voit que de la framboise que
peut être mélangé pied des zones mortes
ici
ça fait très bien homogène c'est le test
du pesto qui a donné le plus de fil à
retordre à nos mélanges art il ya
beaucoup de feuilles qui sont en plus ce
qui risque de se passer
les ambres esprits en l'air puis
descendent pas ils vont pas se mélanger
après 30 secondes à basse vitesse les
herbes rend pas en contact avec la lame
donc on va devoir aller tenir dix
meilleures audiences
on va lui donner un petit coup mais
encore donc si on voit vraiment des
graines de tournesol encore semble
tourner d'enlever d'un peut sensiblement
le même problème avec le ninja
malgré sa conception unique on a ici
trois lames horizontales et par hélène
ce qui fait que les allemands tour mais
les allemands sont pas attirés vers une
langue qui voit vraiment venir frapper
sur chacun les ingrédients pour bien les
mettre en purée ou bien les mélanger de
plus le fabricant indique que cet
appareil ne peut recevoir de liquide
chaud ce qui lui a valu d'être déclassé
par notre expert trois modèles ont des
récipients moins deux blocs 1 et où
selon notre expert le monobloc est
tellement simple alors j'ai pas de
morceaux tout est là je m'installe sur
la base c'est fini c'est réglé pour un
appareil avec un fond qui se dévissent
c'est sûr que moi personnellement j'ai
peur de perdre les morceaux j'ai peur de
les briser cet appareil sa part de 40 $
ça va jusqu'à 160 dollars est ce que ça
vaut le coup et ce qui est des
différences de prix qui parlent ce que
je me suis rendu compte ce qui en mode
100 dollars oui les appareils vont finir
par brouiller par mélanger mais pau où
s'est rapidement et pas aussi ou six
films
pour la simplicité de son design sa
fonction des vitesses ajustable et ses
excellentes performances à chacun des
tests
notre expert nomme gagnant sans
hésitation le modèle le plus cher salton
sea c'est important pour vous d'avoir
des performances si c'est important
d'avoir un produit fin une belle texture
c'est définitivement le meilleur à paris